I'm paola badosa and I'm going to tell you things to get
to know me better, well, yes, I was born
in the USA because my parents, well, they
were working there for a long time and by
chance I was born there, I lived until I was
7 years old, the truth is that I have
few memories, I remember very little, I
remember having started  I went to school there
but not much else because I started playing
tennis when I arrived in
Spain, fashion is something that I love,
I have always liked
designers a lot and that is quite simple, I
like to go quite basic casual and not
invent much with things, but  a
favorite designer so I
really like assembling and above all and well
I was lucky at the time because
my parents worked with them and I
knew him so it might be one of
my favorites I love it and in fact I've
been several times because  my mother
loves going to paris and we have gone several
times we have even come on
weekends just to be there to go shopping
so if they see me i like it a lot for
the restaurants eat very well in
paris bad luck that there are a lot that I am
very abrasive that that is bad but but
we have a great time and we go a lot
[Music] well
the truth is that both of us take it
very positively maybe at the time
when  I was younger, it cost me more because of the
pressure, the expectations of comparing myself
with such a great player and that in the
end I think it is also difficult
because she is a unique person unmatched
but it is good that they compare me with a
player yes and in the end she is also my
idol  something that means to me
motivates me because I think it's a good
comparison
I understand French almost perfectly sometimes
I speak it but it costs me a little more but
I do understand it perfectly and in the end
I'm from Barcelona it's good I'm a
little more from the north of  catalonia then
we are very close to france and in fact
we go quite a lot with my family we try to
go especially to the south which is an
hour away by car and france has always been
a country where we have been  a lot where my
first tournaments as an international sub
12 hour brag about pitita I played
there in the end I have very good memories
because that's when I started to
play international
French hip hop gypsy bonjour even a little later I
always said a word that was
possible and merci  beaucoup
that's what I won roland garros juniors
I have a very special memory whenever
I go there because I get a little emotional
because all those
memories come to mind a
special moment and also what I'm going to tell you
last year because I have my best result
of  grand slam is also in roland garros
so it is something that I have a lot of
love for and I really want it to
arrive because I
have spectacular memories they have three bye